GOING.
HERE HE COMES.
PETTERSSON THROUGH THE N N
PETTERSSON HERE IN VANCOUVER.
HASN'T GOT OFF TO THE OFFENSIVE
FIGHT FOR SCHENN TO TAKE EARLY
ON.
WE SAW HIM HAVE A SPIRITED FIGHT
VANCOUVER.
TRAVIS GREEN HAPPY TO SEE THAT.S
THE PHILADELPHIA FLYERS A COUPLE
OF NIGHTS AGOGO.
IT'S PASS, A
ONE-TIMER!
THATCHER DEM FOEGELE
SCORES FOR THE OILERS!
[ Cheering and Applause ] WHEREK
GOES AND FOR EXAMPLELE IS RIGHT.
THE TOP UNIT FOR EDMONTON STAYS
OUT THERE A LONG TIM
ROLE.
A STEAL A UP.
LOOK AT THER WEAPON AS SCOTT
MENTIONED.
THE SECOND PERIOD THE
CANUCKS.
THE OILERS, THE SHOT DIDN'T GET
THROUGH.
EKMAN-LARSSON TEES IT
[ Cheering and Applause ]
THE EDMONTON OILERS TWO BIT
BUT JUST SO MANY D
>> Harnarayan: THANK YOU,
SCOTT.
McDAVID SCORING BY THATCHER
DEMKO WHO ABSOLUTELY SHUT THEON.
PULJUJARVI AND HYMAN ALL OVER.
CONOR
GARLAND BUT NO, THE BOTH ENDS,
HORVAT BUT FIRST GARLAND WITH A
CHANCE BUT HE CANANLAND TRIES T.
DIDN'T GET ANYTHING ON IT.
PEARSON LOOKING FOR -- SHOOTS
THIS IS WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
THIS GAME.
McDAVID TO THEONAL PLAYS OFF
THE PAD KICK THERE WITH A NICE
SAVE ANS IT BACK,
ONE-TIMER, BROCK BOESER AND HE
GOT A LOT ON IT THIS COMES UP AS
AN AGGRESSIVE CROSS-CHECK IN TIP
BOESER WANTED A CALL NO CALL ON
THE PLAY.
BUT THEY GO TO WORK AND WIN THE.
MILLER.
A SHOT AND MIKKO KOSKINEN!
EKMAN-LARSSON WITH A GREAT
THERE ITIDE.